police in Ireland have revealed the
identities of the 10 people killed in
the huge explosion at a petrol station
in County Donegal including a
five-year-old girl and her father the
victims have been named as James o
flatty who was 48 years old Jessica
Gallagher 24 Martin McGill 49 a 39 year
old Catherine O'Donnell and her 13 year
old son James Monahan Hugh Kelly 59
Martina Martin 49 Robert Gore for 50
years old and his five-year-old daughter
Shauna Flanagan Gore and Leona Harper
who was 14.
continue to investigate all the
circumstances into the cause of a fatal
explosion at a premise increased luck
County Donegal on Friday the 7th of
October 2022.
the investigation is being coordinated
from an instant room at Milford Garda
station
the Garda technical Bureau with
assistance from other agencies will
continue to examine the scene which
remains cordoned off
these examinations are likely to
continue over the coming days
traffic diversions on the n56 at the
scene of the instant remain in place
a total of 10 fatalities have been
confirmed arising from this fatal
explosion
the remains of the deceased are at
Letterkenny University Hospital where
State postmortems have commenced under
the direction of Dr Heidi hawker's
assistant State pathologist
the postmortons will continue over the
next few days results will not be
released for operational reasons
one male in his twenties remains in a
critical condition in Saint James's
Hospital Dublin and the Seven other
surviving casualties also continue to
receive treatments at Letterkenny
University Hospital and remain in a
stable condition
the 10 fatalities included Four Women
sorry four men three women two teenagers
one male and one female and one younger
female child
guard of family liaison officers have
been appointed to the families and
continued to support and provide them
with information
with the consent of the families on
gardisher Corner can confirm the
identities of the deceased as follows
James O'Flaherty 48 years
Jessica Gallagher 24 years
Martin McGill 49 years
Katrin O'Donnell 39 years and her son
James Monaghan 13 years
Hugh Kelly 59 years
Martina Martin 49 years
Robert Garaway 50 years
and his daughter Shawna Flanagan Garaway
five years
and Leona Harper 14 years of age
and our correspondent to Tom palmander
is there for us this lunch time and and
Tom the the emotion are also very clear
there during the press conference and
and the the very local aspect of of all
of this tragedy
you even start with the names and faces
and smiles that we see in all of those
photographs that the Irish police have
released with the consent of the
families who are of course struggling to
comprehend the loss that they have all
suffered here and they're all from this
area those 10 individuals who just
happen to be at this service station one
of the busy shops in this small rural
community at 3 20 in the afternoon on
Friday when that gas explosion which we
believe
occurred in one of the apartments above
the service station
it ripped through that building sending
debris flying and as Rescuers
desperately battled to get to the scene
to try and pick people out of the rubble
before the Emergency Services were even
here it was clear that there would be a
significant loss of life and the
confirmation of the names and ages just
desperately desperately sad and among
those who have been confirmed dead a
five-year-old girl Shauna flanahan
Galway at which she we understand was in
the shop with her father 50 year old
Roberts Galway and they were buying a
birthday cake for Shauna's mum and
desperately sad scenario that really is
quite difficult to take in and that is
certainly something that is going
through this community at the moment
just the scale of loss from This
Disaster and something that will take
many years to recover from we also know
of the other victims Leona Harper was
just 14 years old a very popular sporty
young woman whose Rugby Club letting
letter Kenny the nearest Big Town to
hear pay tribute to her saying it was
just a heartbreaking situation and her
father
has thanked them for that message and
has said that the past 24 hours have
been a sheer hell a desperately sad
situation and then as we see now the
faces of those who lost their lives
and all those lives cut so tragically
shorts and we know that there is still
one man in a critical condition in
hospital he's in his 20s being treated
in Dublin he was taken by an air
ambulance and is being treated for a
very serious Burns and seven others who
were injured in the explosion are being
treated at the more local hospital
Kelly they are all in a stable condition
but so many people in this small rural
community touched by This Disaster many
people here know all of the victims and
the Irish police have now named
Tom Palmerton thanks so much